now Eddie Wu has been dubbed Australia's
best school teacher his infectious
enthusiasm for numbers is unique
teaching styles has made of a massive
hit with students if they described as
the Kim Kardashian of mathematics his
lessons have now become internet
sensations being watched by millions
around the globe what's something you
would feel confident explaining in front
of other people it would be lovely to
get up to clone Eddie will so that you
had a range of him he [ __ ] me in don't
say it but he's actually into math well
Eddie Wu makes math fun there's a lot
more to math than just numbers and not
just for his students at cherry book
technology high school in Sydney's
Northwest is there anyone who still
doesn't have their name down he's viral
YouTube channel woo tube has millions of
fans it's difficult to understand really
how someone in Sydney can influence
thousands of people across the whole
country a gifted student himself
Eddie's parents dreamt of him becoming a
doctor or lawyer my brother then said I
am going to choose education I want to
be a teacher and the air was heavier
then you really could cut the air with a
knife a decision he's thousands of
students are forever grateful for my
game I just have you have a message
driver Cinco de finibus
the team whatever potentially there's no
doubt that teach this generally changed
lives
and somebody is motivated and as
wonderful as it undoubtedly will and the
inimitable mr. Wu joins us now good
morning to you Eddie
every minute second to be here great to
have you very lovely to have you here
now Matt's obviously isn't everyone's
cup of tea you all there their forte but
you it seems to me that it's a
combination of the force of your
personality and your sheer passion for
numbers that get people interested well
yeah what for you what's the key to a
you know wooing students into a love of
that well mathematics is challenging for
a lot of people and I think we need to
remember mathematics you know we haven't
evolved to be good at mathematics
most of what our kids learn even your
seven-year 8u9 for centuries people
thought negative numbers that crazy you
know square roots you know ridiculous or
even even the word irrational numbers
which is a number it's snuck into our
languages meaning crazy because that's
the way you know mathematics is counter
intuitive in something like some ways
but I think that really grabbing that
personal connection with students
helping them understand you know you can
solve problems when you have access to
this kind of knowledge and skill and
that's amazing for them I guess do you
know sorry every second of every day we
are making you know quite a complex
mathematical calculation without
realizing that mathematics is everywhere
I mean one of my favorite examples even
just apart from the practical stuff
about you know where you're going to be
trying to calculate change or making
sure you're not getting ripped off on
your equity bill sure even when you look
at and it should have been a rainy day
the Sun comes out and you see a rainbow
in the sky and a rainbow is this perfect
circle why is it that actually this is
lovely piece of geometry that explains
that so mathematics is everywhere hiding
in plain sight and the fact that you can
do that not just for the keep in your
class but to millions of kids around the
world who watch your your YouTube
channel I think that is extraordinary
did you ever imagine that that is about
that sort of reach you would have that
sort of reach when you defied your
parents wishes and become a doctor or a
lawyer
ah look I I think it's pretty clear
actually that I did not imagine that
which is obvious to anyone who just go
look at my first videos I mean they're
pretty rubbish
I don't play you can tell I'm not even
seeing the frame you can hardly hear me
but I mean to me it's been just as
pleasant surprise and it's obviously hit
and need that people have I know a lot
of people say oh I don't like math for
you I don't buy that I don't think
anyone has anything against numbers or
shapes it's that people don't like
feeling stupid you know any math is hard
and when you look at something you don't
understand it or you don't know how to
solve it it's pretty easy to think ah
this is just too hard for me but what
you are unable to they love it more than
I should feel more stupid a lot more of
the time but we're just those
personalities are dying it is so awesome
when you get a maths problem right like
even stable that love writing um when
you get a mess on right there's a right
and there's a wrong you know it's one of
those few black-and-white moments is
right we're live I think it's immensely
satisfying you don't need to teach a
child how to put together a jigsaw
puzzle they just start to shuffle things
around and then when they get to the end
I think I've done this this is it's a
great accomplishment and I know my
students it resonates with them a lot of
personal landlady I mean your
grandparents from China appearance
within in Malaysia they moved to
Australia you were born in Australia and
you're your own schooling you know you
were subject to kind of the the everyday
racism that the bullying that was quite
common in those times from people of you
know non-english or non-anglo
backgrounds and has that experience in
your own life brought something to your
teaching I definitely think that you
know the journey that I've had going
through school and especially know what
it was like being a very isolated child
and not having heaps of friends and not
really understanding what was my place
in this you know among my friends and
lucky appears has had a huge impact on
me as a teacher it gives me a real
awareness even just some walking through
the school on playground duty I can see
you know hundreds of kids and the
playground and sometimes someone would
just usually fade into the magnetic
leave by themselves but I've you know
through what I've gone through the last
few years I've gained a real eye for
those kids and I really want to seek
them out
Eddie 31 you've had three children you
must be tired I get energy what do you
want look I like to think I'm working
with children keeps me young
it's very healthy you know really
honestly and people say to me are you
know in the classroom it's great to see
your energy and your passion but in all
truth I think that I get so much energy
from the kids I I can see the looks on
their faces even when they're if they're
confused it's because they're trying to
wrap their head around something and
it's not easy
and then when their eye is just kind of
widen I mean look that keeps me going
every day I get out of bed in the
morning I know I'm there for a reason
clearly difference in it yes a brilliant
thing is that you know I was sitting you
thinking I want my kids to be taught by
you but you can get on - whoo - but
thank you and I check you out
thank you so much so lovely to meet you
Eddie what a lot